小英總統講到有六大產業要補值
話中有話是什麼
解封後一定會有報復性的狂吃大碗
餐飲股呢 股價還在比較低的位置
滷肉飯都跟貂蟬一樣
是 如果去這家餐廳吃飯
哇
對 都幫我賺錢
那台灣強的呢 不只生技醫療
台灣人的腦袋也很強
覺得XX的設計也會不錯
小哥去年有沒有戴口罩
我們家口罩是SARS的存貨
17年
如果17年以後沒有SARS
沒有五萬病毒
你不是套牢一輩子嗎
聽說小哥跟華倫老師是首度同台
對啊 以前沒有碰過
怎麼會這樣
都投資領域的啊
可是你們兩個有一個很強烈的共通點
不是體型
雙帥嘛
雙帥
都很帥
而且重點是你們
還以為你要說雙思耶
不是啦 雙思是對的
因為兩位都是李化老師
對 李化老師都在做股票
雖然做的方法不一樣
可是這讓我非常好奇
為什麼
所以教李化是不是
對做股票有一定的幫助
邏輯推理會比較強
那華倫老師你推什麼
沒有 我本來是教數學
因為數學沒有缺
後來學校叫我去教李化
他又沒有缺了
我只好去做股票
對 後來發現找到了我的專長
這叫吉人面向
沒有 真的是邏輯啦 真的是邏輯啦
真的是邏輯對不對
我是覺得理化這個字很棒
理解別人的話
對 因為最近有很多話需要理解
什麼東西需要理解咧
等一下請兩位靠你們囉
我們要來好不好
今天的理財達人秀
兩位理化老師
一個華倫老師
一個小哥
兩位要來理解什麼話呢
大家最近最常听到的一场演说是什么
就是520总统的就职演说了
可是你可能跟赵华一样
如果你听到政治人物在讲话
你听完了你会想
他刚刚在讲什么
我怎么一句都听不懂
但没关系
这次我们的小英总统讲到
有六大产业要扶植
可是我相信你听完了
你其实不知道怎么买
今天两位李化老师
教你来理解小英总统的话
到底六大产业其实
只要好不好
两位老师会凝聚在同样的产业里面
省去你很多的麻烦事
我们来来看一下好不好
总统的话中有话是什么
六个产业嘛
快速念过
数位之通队伍强
5G资安护自己
生医还有新疫苗
国防航太均明和
再生能源成热点
家家物粮口罩足
吃的喝的拉的杀的
吃了啦 吃了
總統好不好
很高的 政治人物都很高的
有長頭師嗎
有長頭師
來小哥的筆 借我一下好不好
國
國家
對
還
在
戶
國家隊還在戶呢
好厲害的長頭師
是不是這樣
長在這裡
你怎麼知道
因為我雖然不是念理化的
但是我理化成績還不錯
原來是這樣
但是要兩位達人幫我驗證
聽完小英總統的六大產業之後
你覺得怎麼解讀小哥
怎麼解讀
我覺得在台灣
是
真的滿幸福的
要口罩有口罩
而且台灣今年最標的股票
就是口罩概念股
你不要再說了
買不到的事情都不要再說好嗎
買不到
你買不到哪一檔
當然就是那個很大
很大
你上次说你喜欢巨大
这次又喜欢很大
很大哪一支
但是因为它可能太大
所以我就没有接受它
太大 你是说这个吗
零确诊台湾太风光这个吗
对
从总统的谈话里面
我觉得未来这个股票
我们要找几下一档
跟恒大类似的
小英没说的小哥来说
你认为总统的话就是零确诊
台灣太風光了
台灣太強了
太強了
那台灣強的呢
不只生技醫療
那還有什麼
台灣人的腦袋也很強
腦袋也很強
對啊
所以台灣下一個
我覺得IC設計也會不錯
等等等等
我跟你講
你不要再提這個恆大了
恆大
看了心情就不好
為什麼
沒有買到嗎
沒有買到啊
天天在跑啊
很誇張
對
他管理年限500%了
我跟你講
我代表散戶的憤怒
所以小哥
你等一下
请勋照下一档很大
好
那是你的功课
照
有点接近的
好
不能很小
要很大
很大
好
接下来
在旁边已经有点下到的华伦老师
是 我想先听小哥讲答案
我有点迫不及待很大
等一下
华老师学坏了
我先讲我的
小英梅说的华伦老师说
解封后景气必回温
一定会有报复性的狂吃大碗
但这有陷阱
什么陷阱
以前我们男生都要当兵
当兵有时候休假到出去放假
然后看到路上的女生
当兵就是母猪在貂蝉
幸好造化本来就是貂蝉
不怕不怕
我们只要看到女生
因为好久没看到女生了
女生每个都是貂蝉
我们这个一样
我们这个封城
在家里关这么久
好不容易下零确诊
我们出去
我们去排那种最好吃的餐厅
定不到位
你已经开始排队了
只好去定第二好吃的
又还是定不到位
那怎么办
所以母猪赛貂蝉
所以隔壁的卤肉饭
那个也很好吃
但是这个不是长久的
有些公司它可能短期的获利
景气到可能雨露均沾
大家都现在都好
但是你长期要存股
要长期投资
还是要寻找最有竞争的股票才可以
所以这就是陷阱
兩位李華老師非常棒
他們已經理解總統說的話
各自聚焦
我們先來看小哥好不好
因為小哥連華文老師
都覺得很好奇
我就不信啦
誰是下一檔很大啦
好 這個恆大這檔股票
有兩個特色
兩個特色
它有兩條線
什麼線呢
口罩兩條線
兩條線是這樣
第一個 卷資比高
卷資比就是融卷
跟融資的比率
待會會交
放空跟想要強力買進的人
對 沒錯
對 放空的人多
第二個主力買
最近很多卷資比高的股票
四開頭的
對
很多人都新要疫苗 醫材類的
最近主力買卷資比高都一直高
摔比了啦
摔比了 沒買到
都是造化不敢買的
對啊
這個很害怕
很害怕是最後一隻老鼠
很害怕啊
可是每天一害怕就是10%
沒錯 那我現在教你一招
你就不會那麼怕了
怎麼說
好 待會兒教
我們來看之前最強最強的恆大
一根 兩根 三根
今天又漲停 第四根
真的很火大
因為我在這邊就有人跟我說今年的EPS很高等一下我問華倫老師基本面很好就今年對明年就不知道了
我從來沒看過基本面好的
可以長那麼快的
它真的長得很誇張
對
對啊
不過這已經偷跑了
現在叫你買的
不大敢買
沒辦法
那我們用一個方法去找
類似的股票
什麼樣的方法
什麼方法呢
我們找
卷資比高的
那我們現在教
這個卷資比什麼意思呢
就是融卷余额除以融资余额
再乘以百分之百
称为卷之比
这个卷当分母
当分子
卷当分子 资当分母
那这个大于30%为高卷之比
所以这边的张数越多越多越多
卷之比就会一直往上跑
大于30%代表很多人需要买回来
对
需要买回来
我们来看这个恒大
恒大就是卷之比高的案例
30%很多人需要买回來
是被嘎到需要買回來
被看對
那要有人去嘎它
誰那麼壞
恒大其實被嘎了很多坡了
在之前已經嘎了一坡
二三月嘎了一坡
然後這邊突然掉下
你知道為什麼嗎
為什麼
融券強制回補
在當時融券強制回補的
我要跟你講
這個你運氣好
這阻力還讓你休息一下
沒有再繼續嘎上去
讓你補債多少
那你補在這個四五十塊
那時候如果反手做多就好了
後面你看今天已經到160了
到160了
對 那卷資比你看
這個在前波有個高峰
不過最近的卷資比比較低了
不敢再空了
最近比較奇怪的是
我昨天看重码我覺得很怪
恆大突然融資大增
然後主力賣超
所以
我覺得是不是散戶受不了了
散戶進來了
想要被尬空手尬都受不了了
Yes 他快要不涨了
所以昨天进来之后
今天又拉一个浪闪路很开心
明天就不知道了
没关系我们继续观察
这是恒大
我们可以看到
他后面主力有买
捐资比高
不管他了
好 那我们来看另外一个
国光升
这样也很强
这也太强了
这是有疫苗的
疫苗概念
我们看一下
這個
趙華你還記得這條線什麼線嗎
哪一條線
上面這條線
你這是布林通道嗎
對 布林通道
這是上軌翹
上軌翹
老公開心 老婆也開心
古民也開心
他現在沿著上軌
然後現在呢
他主力前波是賣超的
不過最近開始買回來
他昨天呈現資真 眷真
資真 眷也真
资争 眷争就是跟他拼了
跟他拼了 两边来火拼
做多跟做空在火拼了
不怕既然已经被处置了
浇了一盆冷水
不过这冷水还好 才五分钟
太热的话就会再浇一盆
变20分钟
我们看卷支比也蛮高的
卷支比已经到47%了
所以这个卷支比高
沿着上轨的股票
一 不要去空它
二 你要追它
你要記得不要變成最後一隻老鼠
對啊 所以你說像我呢
我不敢 我沒那麼大膽子空這種強勢骨
可是你要我買它
就算前景再好
就算蔡總統講的聲音
就是我們的命位沒辦法
那教你一招
只要離開上軌你就出場
離開上軌就出場
沒進場怎麼出場
好的 那沒關係
李化老師發現這個學生很頑劣
我們再講幾個
讓你比較容易進場的
好
好 我們來看一下這個
世新KY
IC設計的
那IC設計的它
這個也是輔最近也有主力買
對
卷資比也高
然後它比較特別的是
它的節奏
你看一下它節奏是
一紅一黑一紅一黑
貼心的節奏
讓你比較好進場
對
那一紅一黑
那你就記得什麼時候進場
黑的時候進場
對
好符合賞戶的心情
買黑不買紅嘛
對
因為世新KY它發了一堆權證
只要它強勢的那一天
很多權證的買方會進來
隔天這個權證又會倒出來
所以就一紅一黑
一紅一黑
對 這樣就比較好進場了
好 這簡單多了
對 那我們再看下一檔
這個也是IC設計的
贊股票最近很強啊
叫聯發科
這太強了
太強了
本來跟台積電差不多價格
對
現在已經遙遙領先
对我们看到它主力大买
然后它很特别是融资还减
散户跑了
太贵了
那一堆人来放空看它不爽
不要这样
所以我觉得这个是后面有能量的
人家是IC设计非常多年的股王了
没错
那卷质比例到45%了
对
不过刚刚前面赵华有解读
有理解小英的话是六大产业吗
国家队还在户
国家队到底还有没有在户
我们从昨天的资料来看
国家队好像有点跑
怎么可以就职完就跑呢
圈诗又是万一出清
万一就差不多会跑一些
万一出清保平安
那我们看他虽然有跑
他昨天也是买一些股票
第一名国具
国具我长期来看
他主力都呈现卖超
所以筹码来看不大好
买国具小心变成国小
买红海会变什么呢
红海也是关键费钱一直在出
我们上次讲中他了
我们就放过他
昨天蛮厉害的买金元电子
这个怎么会去买封册呢
它今天大涨你知道吗
它出现在我的地板股
连续出现三天
国家队强反弹来着
今天涨了6%
蛮厉害的
居然还买台湾50反1
这个一直其实好像都有大户在买
一直都买
什么避险
国家队还买国光升跟恒大
是不是
就符合
还是有听话
符合老大的指示
民事
要记得买这种生意概念股
但是我们这边有存股派的华文老师
他通常是我们心灵的慰藉你知道吗
因为华文老师永远站在我这一派
就是散户乱买的华文老师就会制止他
例如像刚刚的恒大
口罩股两条线
华文老师
人家说基本面很好
很好啊
這個橫道股王生我這邊也有
你這邊也有啊
請問趙華
難道存古派要存這個
趙華去年有沒有戴口罩
趙華有一點氣喘
其實我長期戴口罩
但是我今年最痛苦就是搶不到了
我是要用的人
你戴口罩應該早就要買橫大了
自己買要自己賺啊
那小哥去年有沒有戴口罩
說沒有 拜託
不然我接不下去
沒有對不對
前面有沒有戴
沒有
明年會不會戴
不會對不對
我們家口罩是SARS的存貨
對 所以已經10年沒帶了
17年
17年沒帶
所以我們看一下恆大
我這邊板子不夠大
所以只有過去4年的EPS
對
它恆大2016年是多少
1.16
2017年0.51
2018年0.7
2019年去年0.43
今年第一季1.多
對啊 華老師
再來到桌上10幾塊
今年第一季
它就賺過去4年加起來了對 可是你現在買要再過17年才會用到口罩那不是要等到17年才解套嗎那如果17年以後沒有SARS沒有五萬病毒
你不是套牢一輩子嗎
對 我是建議啦
你這個
你要買的話
一直敢買一張嘛
你可能不敢買10張
不敢show hand嘛
對
那像我從國
我可能買一些
比較我有信心有把握的
我可能買個500萬 800萬
我這怎麼敢買500萬 800萬
我買一張
那買一張每天又提心吊膽
對啊
那国光生也是一样
过去没有赚过钱
那你投资这个意思是
我就不知道是什么意思
就本梦比
对本梦比
那我比较不会做梦
对我比较务实这样
所以现在买防疫概念股
那个口罩概念
如果不是三月买的话
现在买我就觉得有点太迟了
那你说你可能买了
可能真的你现在买进
也许三根掌停板
对
但是它有可能就拿一天跌停板
而且是賣不出去
你上面上可能漲30%
每天可能跌50%
你都賣不出去
而且通常都會在散戶決定
我就是今天要買了
那一天就會跌停班
通常都是這樣
你看華老師多安慰
那華老師你在看什麼
也分我分享一下
我都還是喜歡
你看喔
再請問趙華一下
你如果不景氣
如果病毒
你要不要吃飯
我要不要吃飯
當然要啊
要吃飯嘛
你可能不會去餐廳吃
那可能会买东西回来吃
还是要吃嘛
所以我们全台湾民众的
总食物量应该不会差太多
对不对
总不能趁机减肥
而且很多人在家
是还吃到爆肥
对 有可能
因为没事做
你可能不会出国
你可能不会出去运动
或者做其他消费
但是你一定要吃嘛
所以我是很喜欢吃的
好 华伦ETF里面
大部分是吃的
我最爱食品股这样
還有吃完就要排泄 排泥
所以我會喜歡收垃圾的股票
再怎麼不景氣
再怎麼有病毒
還是要吃 還是要辣這樣子
好 華倫老師都不避諱
他的華倫ETF
現在市值是超過4000萬
小哥
跟你就是有拼
有拼啦
對不對 可以拼起拼坐
李華老師真的很會賺錢
然後華倫ETF
也跟我們的台灣價值雷同
對 這個我要補充一點
台灣價值啊
早期十几年前
之前的总统也有爆一些名牌
什么两兆双新
什么面板
太阳能
LED
就是现在在叠得很惨
对 变成产业
所以那时候如果十几年前买的话
现在又套牢一辈子
所以我觉得总统爆的名牌
你还是要去判断
要自己好好选
对 那个国家队还在乎
那有几个是我是很喜欢
但有几个像刚刚讲那个
生技医疗
那个可能就有点高了
没关系我跟你一样
我不喜欢那种梦的
所以现在我们可以观察什么
是今年
其实我们还有点机会
因为刚才都高高在天上
现在有没有滴滴在地上
要往上走的
也有
其实我刚刚讲这些食品股
像大统益 中华石 德卖
这些早就已经过
疫情之前的高点了
对 现在就有点比较
所以华伦ETF
现在已经溢价在发行
对 溢价发行
那我们要找折价发行的
看有没有
其实还是有啦
像饭店股
一些饭店股啊
餐饮股可能还在比较
低的低档的水准
可是现在因为解禁
那我们刚刚讲说
大家都闷太久了
所以现在出去餐厅
定位都定不到了
那像我又喜欢这种
民生消费股票
喜欢从日常生活去观察的
那我看到真的很多餐厅
就定不到位了
真的 我自己前两天去百货公司
某一家上市公司的连锁品牌
他跟我说要后位40分钟
我就想什么
对不对
以前是我旁邊四桌沒人桌
現在要後衛40分鐘
瓦城嗎
不能說 不可說
對 我怕粉絲去找我
OK
所以確實有回...
我只能一句說瓦城
那沒有不期而遇
所以最近真的餐廳很難定位
這個狀況開始發生了
但是你說景氣好
但是還是有些飯店撐不下去
對啊 你說什麼大義立志
像雅都
雅都他旗下兩個飯店
一個台南大義立志
一個台中雅都飯店都撐不下去
對 為什麼
要回溫了
他们在忍耐一下
对 他撑不到这一天就挂了
所以其实蛮可惜
因为他本身竞争力其实就不太够
所以两者的差别
其实在一个率对不对
对 就是毛利率 市占率
那像我们刚刚讲很多餐饮股
或说饭店
或说一些酒店这样子
那么市占率其实不是很高
那像我刚刚讲
我喜欢的股票像中华石 大统益
市占率都五六十%
可能每天都要重复消费
可是你不可能每天去住饭店
那毛利率通常要大于20%
可能比较好一点
毛利率会大于20%
因为其实市占率
你说台湾要哪家饭店
或哪家餐厅市占率非常大
其实不太容易
因为它是一个
竞争比较激烈的行业
可是毛利率就可以看得出来了
对 像我每天也不可能去夏都
去寒色 去精华酒店
好想去
对啊 可是就办不到
所以其实就算
这些股票短期如果复苏
那我是建议还是不要追
因为像我投资股票
喜欢投资有护城河的公司
所以饭店股Q1看来双方惨重
所以今年可能有机会赔钱
长期你也不推荐饭店股
至于说餐饮股Q1受到影响
但是其实第一季已经过去了
我们就不用再看了
主要是它的股价还在比较低的位阶
是比较有机会的
有关各股的基本面
我待会再做分析
所以你的意思是饭店股你不会碰
可是餐饮股
因为现在连乳肉饭都跟貂蝉一样
是 没错
所以你覺得餐廳股是有機會的
對…
但是那你的華人WTF為什麼會議價呢
因為就算有疫情的時候
我剛講過
我們還是要吃豆腐
對
還是要吃雞肉
還是要吃麵包
因為你不敢到餐廳坐下來吃飯
那我們要買東西回去
對 所以我這個普通是做雞肉的
中華時是賣豆腐
德賣是賣麵包的
像這些股票
其實第一季的獲益都是
都是歷史算同期的
算新高水準的
像中華食第一季成長48%
德賣成長2%
那現貨果汁就是在大陸
大陸疫情比較慘重
所以衰退87%
下次只要說吃什麼會防疫
可能它第一季第二季都會噴出
是
好 所以華文老師是認為說
像食品股是不管也沒有在防疫
就是你的總食物量是不會下降的
就算你在家吃
你叫UberEats或什麼來
你都是要用的
但是我現在把難題
丢给刚刚一直在做功课的小哥了
对 因为你刚刚讲到两条线
对 我们玩的比较短
我们玩的比较短
它那种比较长的
其实我也觉得也蛮好的
华尔老师你想到17年后
可能不会有SARS
也不会有武肺了
对 我们就是很短
17分钟后会发生什么事呢
看看最近的线哪个在涨
那我们就买什么
很直接
对
那我们从大数据里面去捞
这个1700多档股票里面
我们去捞
剛剛教我們的嘛
高卷之比加上主力還買
嘎的你吱吱叫
對 我們來看一下
這個泰鼎
好
泰鼎昨天
我說到這個功課
我就找一下
泰鼎它就符合高卷之比
對
卷之比已經快到30%了
已經26%已經算有點高
對這有點溫水煮青蛙的味道是那主力最近也在買結果今天你知道怎麼樣加漲停板又一個10%
對
這功課才剛做完又漲停
不過低跟漲停還好啦
你只要看到恆大那種
我們就追不下去
現在跟別的比就覺得他還好
不是很腰還可以
好那第二檔呢
就股價就躺在這邊
沒什麼動
杨明光
这个以前好像也曾经主力爱过他
这档比较乖一点
你看最近股价都没什么动
可是你看这卷值比蛮高的
好像有人在空他
因为以前的就是有一些印象
怪怪的
不喜欢他长
他又有一个波段主力在里面
所以杨明光最后到底是波段主力获胜呢
还是这个龙卷获胜
所以他也符合高卷值比
加上现在主力躲在里面买
他现在主力有在买
而且股价还没有明显的波动
股价没什么动
阳明光怪怪的
好 观察它
观察它
小哥常说不是叫大家买
是叫大家观察它
没错
然后观察就买不到
对 就买不到
好
这个不要去追它
不要去追它
有些人追高
因为追高后面跌下来就不大好了
好
第三档呢
这个
也是高卷之比
也是主力最近买
可是你会觉得怪怪的华航
没有 我跟你讲
人家都已经个位数股价了
你还去放空它也有点
但是你要去买它也有点
很怪
就不要理它
对 你说华航再不飞下去
可能航空公司都会出问题
对不对
对啊
这种高卷之笔比较特别
因为它有发行可转载
这什么密码
它发了两档
发了有什么问题吗
发可转载就有人会玩动态避险
东太避险太难了
太难了
李化老师讲人话
讲人话
就是有人会买华航的可转债
空华航的股票
只要大涨没关系
我有可转债
可转债会赚钱
只要大跌没关系
我有融券
我赚钱
我有赚钱
所以大涨大跌都赚钱
难度有点高
对 那叫可转债
那由于大涨大概都赚钱了
所以这涨了
它不一定会大涨
所以这种高卷之笔主力买的
它不一定会涨
那会怎么样
因为它有可转载
所以就是高卷之笔加主力买
但是要记得
它有发可转载的时候
有可转载的避开
对 因为它就不是会喷的股票
又学了一招
所以这个华航的话
我相信华人老师看了也是怕怕
对 巴菲特都把航空都是卖光了
就贫航
贫航對不對
但是剛剛有提到
其實華文老師有壓寶
壓軸在最後
到底我們現在那麼多的餐廳
你去吃是不是你就會買它
有可能
我們買股票
投資股票是看未來
對
武漢肺炎
這個五肺都過去式了
過去的EPS不好就過去
讓它過去了
因為現在你看
零確診已經非常多天了
對
我們看到瓦城
過去1 2 3 4 5 6
每年都EPS
每年都一直成长
从10块成长到15块
所以华文老师
你是去视察你的旗下企业
一定会
因为你是他股东嘛
是 对 就会
那我对照刚刚讲过一张板子
对
我们刚刚说很大对不对
你看他过去
大家都不戴口罩的时候
EPS很惨 就零点多
对
那如果说今年明年大家戴口罩
后年不戴口罩
刚刚小哥说都不会戴口罩了
对
那他以后的EPS就回到这样子
所以股價是就打回去
对
那相反喔
那你看瓦城第一季是不是不好
对
那可是等疫情结束之后
大家都去瓦城吃月亮虾饼
不是一票就回去了吗
回去股价就回去了
我觉得瓦城真的应该给我们一些餐券
我们都免费这样帮他宣传
需要需要
所以我觉得瓦城老板
赵华套你了
好不好 徐老板
对 我超爱月亮虾饼
好 超爱月亮虾饼
对
好 除了瓦城勒
我们还可以吃什么
对 另外一家捐豆腐韩式料理
这也是百货公司常看到的品牌
对 购物中心百分公司都有
对
因为我买这个股票
存股长期投资
我都会看到过去的获利
有些公司的毛利率不好
竞争率不好
它的EPS
它的税后经历会忽高忽低
可是由于这个豆腐
它今年应该全台湾
大概有四十几家店吧
应该四十几家
所以它在展店的阶段
所以看EPS不准
因为它股本有膨胀的关系
所以我们看税后经历比较准
好
税后经历也是从
104年的6900萬到去年已經1.3億了
所以它是長期成長的趨勢
那其實第一季獲利也是不錯
對 它好像比較沒有受到疫情的影響
所以這兩支股票算是餐廳股票
我比較覺得比較好一點
而且股價又在第一檔
所以黃老師
這跟你手上的中華石還相呼應
它需要很多豆腐
需要
然後呢
所以你的中華石跟它就會一起
所以我去這家餐廳吃飯
哇
重拾兩家餐廳
對…都幫我賺錢
所以一魚兩隻
一豆腐牠吃兩遍
這樣滿好的
真的滿好的
但是吃完了
你剛有提到嗎
我們吃完了我們還會把它
把它運出來是不是
所以你還會再去它的下游
再撈一趟
對 像前幾天黃金不太好的時候
黃金不太好
黃金是垃圾
垃圾就變黃金了
日友8341
今天股價創歷史新高
所以你過去任何時候買金都賺錢
它是毛利率幾%
毛利率紅色的線是日游
70幾%
贏大利光
另外一家可寧位也是70幾%
昆鼎也有30幾%
為什麼毛利率這麼高呢
大家不喜歡做這個行業
不是不喜歡 是大家喜歡但是進不來
有門檻 有執照的問題
它是特許行業
一般環保團會抗議
蓋個掩埋場 焚化爐其實很困難
所以基本上他們是非常有互承河競爭
定价能力是比较高
好 我懂你的意思
不要买黄金
要买另类的黄金
有味道的黄金
好 有味道的黄金
好 所以今天又非常谢谢两位达人
给你一定非常多的概念
就是今天我们听完一个政治的演说之后
事实上它会反映在股价上
这不是乱讲的
而且大家不要忘记了
请上网搜寻我们理财达人秀的精英班
因为我相信你看完这短短30分钟
一定不过瘾
你一定想要了解更多
知道更多
所以加入我们金星班
是一个最棒的选择
今天两位李化老师来到现场
一个是小哥
一个是华伦老师
两个都从理解人话的角度告诉你
六大产业你该买什么
很清楚了
小哥教你从卷资比加主力买
帮你筛股了
华老师告诉你
Q1不好不代表今年都不好
有景气复苏股正在复苏
所以今天的精髓你们掌握到了吗
理财大量秀今天就到这边了
我們下次再會囉
拜拜